[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make way for
one of the great executives in tv
history nbc
universal sports the olympics he also
was one of the creators of saturday
night live
oh by the way he's dick ebersol who
joins us on the program
dick good morning thanks for joining us
we wanted to talk about
25 years ago this week muhammad ali
lit the olympic torch in atlanta and i
was curious
the back story of that like how did you
keep that secret from
everybody including those who probably
worked for you
um well it started dan a few days before
christmas in uh i guess it would have
been the games were in what 96 so it had
been
just christmas week in 95 and i was in
billy payne's office he was the
head of those games he'd gotten the
rights to the games for athens
or not athens but atlanta and he
when asked by me who had he decided
would like the cauldron he said
holyfield
and i said billy i just don't think
that's a good idea i just don't think he
really has that stature i know he's a
local guy but
there's somebody who's much better uh
for this and he said who and i said
muhammad ali
and he said in all earnestness he said
dick i just think i'll have a terrible
time trying to sell
that here in atlanta and i said billy
it's just it's just not comprehending
what ali
is all about at this stage of his life i
think he's probably the most beloved
person
in the entire world other than probably
the pope
he's appreciated by young people by
people who are now
well beyond their youth who watched his
valiant fight for what he thought was
right
he gave up his prime burning years
the sacrifices were enormous he put
everything on the line
and to show you how strong he held his
opinions he sat on those
sidelines for several years losing that
money
and in the meantime he
really really uh tested out the court
system
and he won a unanimous verdict from a
very very
uh conservative u.s supreme court i
think it was eight to nothing
he was vindicated and he went back to
fighting again and
billy said geez i don't still don't
think i know enough and remember lisa
lacks who worked for us at
nbc she was our primary filmmaker dan
and she
i said i want you to make this film i
called don hewitt the 60 minutes
executive producer and he had been the
most recent interviewer
he'd had somebody from his staff had
been in cuba about
two weeks before and done an interview
with ali and lisa cut all this stuff
together through the ages
and we sent it to billy this would have
been in the spring of
96 and he watched it and he got a
pretty strong sense of you know what
this real
ali was uh was all about but he's still
a little uh reluctant and at that point
i
got off the phone and called andrew
young who was
a prominent member of the the board for
the atlanta games the former ambassador
the united nations among other things
uh big deal in georgia and i said you've
got to push billy over the line and
within a day he did
and billy always always
appreciated that fact and as
clinton told it clint clinton told me
the day after
the torch lighting and not the torch
lighting but the cauldron lighting in
atlanta he said when ali appeared
the world heard the loudest hush in
human history because when he came
up uh over the rim of the stadium uh
and the public science it wasn't
initially cheers it was this kind of
an enormous ah kind of
sound that was just everywhere and what
a lot of people forget
they spent a fortune building this ramp
on the exterior
of what became turner field so that the
athletes could gradually walk up five
stories
and come up over the rim of the stadium
as as opposed to in the past all olympic
ceremonies
they'd come walking in some gate into
the stadium but here
they just appeared and when they saw the
athletes coming up and then they saw ali
emerge
it was just unbelievable and as it was
his courage
was on display and i i suggest to people
i don't know how often
you'll be seen again now we've just had
the anniversary but
watch as he holds that torch
to light the arrow not the arrow but the
thing that look
like a little rocket that was going to
shoot up and light the cauldron
and the flames are licking back across
his forearms
and i kept thinking how much longer can
he hold this because it's got to be
burning this
the top of his arms but he did until
this thing lit
he was an amazing amazing character and
i knew him beforehand because of my days
in
wide world of sports at abc but i did
get to know him better
through the years after that in fact
susan gave a birthday party for me
my 50th uh in
97 and it was in a theater
off broadway and it was the theme was
this is your life and they had
pastas play the role of was his name
ralph edwards was he the host of this is
your life yeah
and uh he had a script inside the book
and
the voices would go dick i remember the
time blah blah blah and
all of a sudden out would come like bill
russell and russell
russell who was and still is a very good
friend that goes all the way back to
me being a teenage production assistant
doing nba games
uh while i was still a student at yale
uh russell told the story of the two of
us
not knowing that or driving up route 5
in
from l.a to san francisco him on his way
home to seattle
i didn't know he was doing this and i
was in a porsche i've been
uh unceremoniously uh let go by nbc
entertainment some point before that so
i had decided i woke up one morning i
said i'm gonna see if i can make it from
beverly hills
to the saint francis hotel and san
francisco in under five hours
insane i mean whatever i was thinking so
i'm going uproot five at over 100 miles
an hour
and i notice that this bug this
volkswagen bug
hardtops it keeps getting closer to me
it's like hanging off the
left side of my car but not quite where
i can see the driver
and then i realize i can't see the
driver
and then suddenly the thing pulls dead
even and the
horn starts beeping and i look and
russell has leaned forward from the back
seat
and looked at me and he's smiling i know
he's tackling because he doesn't laugh
he tackles
and we pull off a route five and he
tells me that he's gone down to pick up
this car
he'd always wanted to have a volkswagen
bug so he'd removed the front seats
and had an oversized seat put in the
back of it
and he drove from back there dan and we
just stood by the side of the road and
he was here
when the hall of fame ceremonies took
place recently in
connecticut and massachusetts he stayed
here with susie and i
and his wife and his godson you know his
godson is sean kemp jr remember
yeah yeah played for seattle
did uh bob costas know the night of the
uh the ceremony the opening ceremonies
with the torch with ollie did he know
no i never told he or enberg and i only
had one conversation about it i had it
with somebody else that i don't think
you know so i won't mention their name
i just said i think these guys are such
solid pros
that their excitement and their
immediate recall of anything that was
important about ali
would easily meet the test and i didn't
tell them
yeah and they were you know when you
hear the tape even today they're both
extraordinary i mean uh enberg is truly
surprised dick
he is yeah you got a bunch of oh my
yeah i was just curious um bob's recall
was splendid
oh yeah like i mean you had to have
complete trust in them and rightfully so
that
you know they would handle the surprise
but they would also give you the
backdrop of
what this moment means that ollie
battling parkinson's
um you know even janet evans handing it
off to ali i forgot about
little janet evans the swimmer there um
before i let you go can i
i want to ask one saturday live uh
question
do you remember eddie murphy's audition
or the reaction no i don't and
and here's the interesting thing when i
went back to the show
um oh about
two years after lorne left the first
time we'd started the show together
i left after a bunch of years he stayed
for probably five or six
longer um and then he left and the
person who succeeded him
just didn't know what to do and the show
rapidly fell apart
lauren was asked to go back he still
said no he didn't like silverman nor did
i
but brandon tartikoff who was my best
friend from college years and
until the day he died he talked me into
it
and i came back i did not know any other
than from
being amazed at just how funny he was in
the few shows i'd watched in that period
because the show wasn't very good other
than him
and when i got there it took me about
one week to decide
that the quickest way to at least send
the message out that the show was back
i constructed the show that the first
three acts which is basically 11 30 to
midnight
that eddie would be in every one of them
and they would be ones that he had
conceived and worked on with these two
writers who were his
uh partners in crime comedy crime all
the way until today they've written all
his movies
david sheffield and barry blasting and
uh
he was 19. he was 18 when i got there he
was 18 when i got there
wow and he he he carried the show and
i'll tell you
one one story that you'll just love so i
get uh i'm
back on the show for several months
maybe six
and the security people have called
upstairs at nbc and said that uh
um oh god what's the name of the famous
children's show mr rogers was downstairs
and wanted to see me
so they brought him upstairs and he sat
with me and he just told me how
disappointed he was that eddie was doing
mr
robinson's neighborhood he thought it
was
too tough on the show and i said no it's
as loving as you can get it's him
adapting it
to the circumstances of what a young
black
kid would fully understand and
probably was already a fan of mr rogers
and
he he just didn't want to accept this so
i walked him down the hall
to a room where eddie was one of those
two writers and they talked to him for a
while
he was charmed by it but he came back my
office and he still said i still wish i
couldn't do it anymore but
i just decided to keep pairing it um
and it continued to be one of the two or
three things the audiences wanted to
watch the most and it was a lovely
caricature
did you try to get mr rogers on saturday
night live with
eddie but the fact was he didn't want it
he didn't want mr rogers to air anymore
so there was
no way on earth that he was also gonna
accept an invitation to come to the show
so i never
made the offer because he was really
disappointed that i wasn't just ending
it there and then
in my office hey dick it's great to talk
to you as always i hope you're doing
well my best to uh
susan and the family and uh thank you
again
you're welcome thank you that's dick
ebersol tv executive senior advisor for
nbc universal sports the olympics former
chairman of nbc sports
uh once my boss there at nbc